hello everyone it's Christmas Eve here
and my girlfriend and I were invited to
a party so in case you don't hear from
me tomorrow you know it always depends
how the party will go I thought I'd show
you a nice wild game to fit nicely with
this Christmas spirit the game was
played in 2007 it was the Rui Lopez
festival in Spain and we have a game by
Ruslan polo Mario and even throw club
I've always actually thought him and
Sokolova was a Russian guy but it seems
that he's he's a Dutch grandmaster with
some Bosnian roots and even Sokolov here
he won the Yugoslav championship in 1988
and he won the Dutch chess championship
twice also I think he won one ten years
after he won the us all championship in
1998 so definitely a strong player and
his peak rating was somewhere around
twenty seven hundred and six but that
was more than ten years ago now I think
he mostly commentates on games and
doesn't really play that regularly and
with the white pieces we have a Ruslan
Polo Mario he was a feeder world
champion from 2002 to 2004 he became
feeder world champion by defeating
Vasily Ivanko in the Knockouts so
definitely a strong player and it's a
pretty wild game because it features one
variation that I don't think it's that
often you can see this variation I think
the last time I saw this variation was
when Kramnik was playing that match
against deep Fritz but you know I don't
know I I don't think you can see this
very often but you'll see what I mean
we have d4 by ponomaryov and d5 see for
the Queen's Gambit D captures on c4
Sokolow accepts the gambit and E for now
the central variation and now b5
actually protecting the gambit pawn a
for now
c6 a captures C captures and Knight to
c3 going after the b5 pawn Bishop to d7
again defending Knight to f3 and e 6 and
if you if you ever read any book or
watched any tutorial on the Queens
gambit declined the Queens gambit
accepted you will often hear that it's
it's never a good idea to actually try
and protect the gambit pawn because you
will always mess up somehow but you'll
see what happens in this game Bishop to
e2 with Knight to f6
ponomaryov castles Bishop to e7
d5 now he captures he captures and Queen
to b6 in here we have Bishop to f4
it seems that black even throw club is
ready to castle but castling here
wouldn't be such a great idea for black
sari for example in black castle here
you get this annoying v-6 move now you
have to play Bishop to d8 and after
Knight to e5 it's it's a very passive
position for black Bishop f3 is coming
the bishop boilers from this very strong
diagonal so not a great choice of moves
for blacks so after this Bishop f4
Sokolov played Bishop to c5 kind of not
allowing his Bishop to become almost
trapped with d6 and now so close
definitely is ready to castle but
ponomaryov had had a different idea here
he played Bishop captures on c4 and this
is one of those sacrifices that you
can't really decline if you decline it
you just lost the pawn and you you're
just worse so the bishop is accepted
this B captures on c4 and now Queen to
e2 check unfortunately you can't block
this check with anything if you try
something like Bishop to e7 simply rook
to e1
white will win back the piece and being
at the pawn it's it's a probably a
winning game but after Queen to e2 King
to f8 was played by Sokolov and now
comes Knight to e5 the idea is so
problematic didn't want to capture this
pawn would the Queen he played nice to
e5 he wants to capture with the night if
the Queen capture that then moves like a
5 and Queen before our coming you know
if if black manages to exchange Queens
here he will be he will be fine
so after 95 Bishop to f5 and now comes
Knight to a4 attacking the Queen and the
dark square Bishop so Queen to b5 Knight
captures on c5 Queen captures on c5 and
nice
captures on c4 and so far for the
sacrificed piece ponomaryov has only one
pawn so one poem for the sacrifice piece
but it's a it's a mighty pawn this best
D pawn could you know could soon become
a queen but we'll see how it goes
quaint to d4 and the Bishop to e5 now
since the bishop was attacked the bishop
moves with a tempo now comes the Bishop
d3 and now both queens are attacked for
a matter of place Queen to d2 and here
we have Queen captures on d5 so what's
the idea why did wanna Mario give up at
the d5 pawn he plays rook F to D 1 now
with a double attack on the bishop so
call of place Queen captures on c4 and
now pony might've doesn't capture the
bishop people is a rook a to C 1 we have
Queen to a6 and now Paula Mario is
actually done to pieces and he lost his
very important central pawn so what what
is he doing here it's very you know if
you simply capture the bishop okay you
you win a piece but you're down to
pieces this achieves nothing but he
plays Bishop captures on f6 and this is
the wild move that completely destroys
black what's happening here if you play
Queen captures on f6 you get Queen to b4
check and it's pretty much game over if
you block check the rook c8 is checkmate
if you don't block it if you play
something like King to e8 then comes to
rook e1 check King d8 Queen to b7 and
there are all sorts of threats Queen c7
is checkmate to rock the c8 is checkmate
there is no defense would best defense
which are basically just silly moves
it's checkmate in eight so after this
Bishop captures on f6 you can't capture
with the Queen but can you capture with
the pawn for example G captures on f6
not really Queen to h6
would come this is which check King g7
rook to e1 check King to d8 and now
Queen to f4 threatening Queen the c7
checkmate so after we block this with
Queen to b6
then you get to Queen to f3 this comes
with an attack on the bishop also
attacking the rook on a8
both of rooks are cutting off the king's
escape routes this is this is
this is winning for white so after this
Bishop to f6 circle of the clients the
bishop and he plays the Knight to d7
developing a piece and now preparing to
capture the bishop
we have Bishop back to c3 Bishop to b5
now since the bishop was attacked twice
Queen to g5 and we have Knight to f6 now
Queen to c5 with check King to g8 and
now again we have Bishop captures on f6
and it's amazing that again this is
twice in this game that ponomaryov
capped we played Bishop captures on f6
and again you can't capture with the
Queen or with the pawn now if you play
Queen captures on f6 you get to Queen
the c8 check and this is just
devastating black is getting checkmated
rope has to capture rook captures and
now after the Queen blocks and the
bishop blocks the rook will just gobble
up all the pieces and it's checkmate
so after this Bishop captures on f6 you
can't play G captures on f6 but then you
get rook to c3 and there is no defense
against rook to g3
this will count with checkmate you can
try some free moves for example h6
but again Ruby g3 King h7 Queen to a5
this is checkmate so this is pretty
amazing twice in the game ponomaryov
played Bishop captures knight on f6 and
both times you can't capture either with
the Queen or with the Jeep on so h6 was
played here making some room for the
king but now again Bishop back to c3 and
this is one one annoying Bishop rook to
e8 rook to d6 now with a temple on the
Queen on a6 Queen to b7 and we have
Queen to f5 Queen to e7 and this is one
of those moves in the game so Cole was
probably he was probably devastated as
he lost that night twice to Bishop
captures on f6 and here he could
probably hold the position you know we
would move like f6 or or a6 defending
the bishop but he actually played Queen
to e7 he doubled I mean doubled he plays
the Queen and rook on the e-file now he
controls the file you can't really move
the bishop or Queen to
we'll be checkmate and this comes with
stamp on the rook the rook on d6 is
attacked but he missed the simple Queen
captures on b5 and there is no move here
for black to play if you captured the
rook white captures rook would check on
e8 and now actually after all of this
white will be up a piece
so after this Queen captures on b5 the
Dutch Grand Master even focal of
resigned the game so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Marcel Bert Elmer Erik Kay
Dickinson and the Martin Demeter of the
Metro for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon and in
case I don't see you soon since tomorrow
is Christmas and everything
a Merry Christmas to everyone and I hope
you have a fantastic Christmas and the
days that follow Christmas so thank you
all I will see you soon